[Music]
thank you for being here
for the DEA 201 data discovery in Google
cloud session
I am Shekar Bobbitt I'm the product
manager for data catalog as you might be
aware that we announced data catalog
beta yesterday I'll be talking about
data catalog and put it in the context
of something that is on everyone's mind
that is data governance and with me on
stage today I would have Renata sitting
here and the mass both from Gajic who've
been collaborating with us for the good
part of last one year and have developed
applications using the backend of data
catalog and they'll be doing a demo of
that so this is the agenda if you're
going to do an overview talk about the
bigger trends we'll talk about data
catalog the overview the architecture
the various features that we want to
highlight in the context of overall data
governance and then I'll do a little
demo and then I will hand it over to
Renata and remus who will talk about
their application that they have built
for go-jek and they're also going to do
a short demo we hope to fit all this
into the allocated time and also leave
some time for questions so here's the
overview and trends right so what is
driving data governance initiatives a
lot of you are very interested in how to
manage your data how to discover your
data because we are in a world where
there is no shortage of data right data
is everywhere we are drowning in data
the question is how do we make good use
of the data how do we find the relevant
data the right data to drive your
decisions and in the context of things
like GDP are you know California act
hippo etcetera how do we actually govern
the data how do we make sure that the
right people have access to the right
data and then you can generate reports
and be compliant and not get in trouble
right
so there's the risk management part of
it that needs to be managed
there is the operational efficiencies
and other aspects that you need to
tackle and essentially if you do not
manage it you don't have any control
over their data and data governance is
driven by these you know bigger
requirements so in that context data
catalog gives you a framework a
foundation for building your data
governess services and so we have a
pretty aggressive roadmap but we start
with data discovery right because
without proper data discovery you have
nothing and the organization's need an
effective solution for data discovery
right and the challenge of data
discovery is that your data is not all
in one place it's in disparate places
it's in different systems it's spread
all over so how does an analyst let's
take the canonical case of an analyst
who recently joined the organization and
needs to figure out what data what data
they have access to and how they can get
access to it and how do they make sense
of it and there is a need for the data
discovery tool so what we have this is
the context of why it is needed so we
have built a system that provides a
unified view of all your data assets and
we'll start is initially with the data
assets in GCP let's say you have data
assets in GCP and differences of like
bigquery pops GCS and going forward lots
of different systems we give you a way
to discover your data that is spread
across all these systems and it is a
smart catalog in the sense that you have
to do minimal work so before I go into
that a little bit of history right how
did we come across this how did we come
up with this notion of building a data
catalog well Google has been dealing
with a large number of data assets for
many years and Google felt the need to
build something for itself alone back
and we are in our third iteration of
this internal data catalog that handles
more than million objects and it's used
by more than 30,000 active Googlers so
we have built a very scalable system and
now we want to take that underlying
technology
and make the data catalog available to
our GCP customer so that's the history
now talking about the data catalog in
addition to the technical metadata I'll
talk about what is what we consider
technical metadata and what we consider
business metadata we enable users to
annotate business metadata and that too
in a collaborative manner to add overall
value and put data intelligence in the
data assets and as I mentioned earlier
data catalog provides the foundation for
data governance right so data catalog
was in alpha for a while and we recently
announced beta in the current
incarnation this is the overview write
data catalog automatically ingest
metadata from bigquery pub/sub and GCS
and it provides a simple search
interface for data discovery your
technical users as well as your business
users can easily access it it supports
the UI as well as an API so that you can
do all kinds of bulk annotation of data
we have the innovation here in business
metadata instead of having simple tags
we provide schema ties tags to capture
really rich business metadata we'll talk
about that in a moment and as I
mentioned we ought to ingest the data
another strong feature another feature
that I'm very proud of is that we have a
controls on the business metadata that
are also you know very strong and for
technical metadata they're actually
built-in they just leverage the existing
Akal so you as a user have to do very
little extra work the last bullet is
very attractive to many of our customers
because there is a lot of data because
our customers have thousands of let's
say bigquery tables and each has maybe
hundreds of columns and it's very hard
to easily identify PII data so we offer
an integration with DLP data loss
prevention service which automatically
scans the data and creates appropriate
tags to identify sensitive data like the
IR data so a little bit about the data
catalog architecture internally you know
if I have to identify two blocks it's
like we have a metadata store
it's a transactional store and wind
youthspan we also have a search index
that we built in the search index
leverages the same technology that
powers Gmail and Google Drive which has
a context built into it and it's a very
scalable performance system so we know
that we can build a system that is
really really scalable now talking about
you know what does it do to you as a
user
it makes data discovery available at
your fingertips without almost any
additional effort because since the data
catalog automatically syncs all the
metadata from all these various sources
and puts them in index you can do simple
keyword search and anybody can just find
appropriate magics if you're a power
user it also enables you to do facets
search just like you can do 4G Drive or
or Gmail right so you can say okay I
want to look only for table names or
look only for certain views or I want to
look for assets where the column matches
a particular keyword or I have created
tags that say hey this is PII so show me
everything that matches bir and in the
demo I will show more but a combination
of simple keyword search and really
powerful facet search enables you to do
data discovery very very easily now in
addition to the UI as I mentioned if you
have lots and lots of data in order to
annotate them in an effective way we
enable you to do bulk updates of
metadata through API and in beta we are
going to be supporting Python Java and
node.js language libraries to make it
very easy for you to do the API
integration in a in a programmatic way
now API enables our customers to build
enterprise applications that are very
specific to their needs it also enables
customers to build their own front-end
if they choose to do so and use the data
catalog back-end
I would like to point out that you know
go-jek is one of our customers who have
worked closely with us and build such a
front-end and there will be on stage
here with me shortly to do a demo of
that
so you know I talked briefly I kind of
referred to technical and business
metadata and since its kind of central
to my discussion I want to spend just
few seconds talking about our notion our
terminology you know what is technical
metadata and what is business metadata
right so technical metadata is things
like table names data sets name column
names table descriptions date created
date modified etc the metadata that is
already there in the source system that
we refer to as technical metadata and as
I mentioned earlier we automatically
sing that metadata from the source
system into Data catalog and put that in
the index so if you create a new table
in bigquery within like three seconds
that metadata shows up there is no need
for you as a user to manually register
these data assets right so that is
automatic but in addition to that there
is a lot of business context that needs
to be attached to the data things like
well does this data set have PII or who
is the data owner does it have a delete
by requirement delete by certain date or
does it have a retain till certain date
requirement what is the data quality
score right what is the cardinality
there's all kinds of other relevant
information that needs to be stored and
without a proper system to store this
metadata our customers tell us that well
they leave it in some wiki page some
confluent page or some you know
spreadsheet and it's not very searchable
and it's not very usable did I
accidentally click that okay sorry so I
am having some clicker issues all right
now
here's the example on the right side of
what the business metadata looks like
right so the business metadata is
schematized tags as I mentioned unlike
other data catalogs where the business
tags can be simple text strings we allow
you to capture really rich business
metadata using schema we believe that
just like when you have complex data you
need schema to manage it since you have
complex metadata we give you the ability
to create schema for you metadata we
call them templates so a template
can have multiple fields and you can
have I don't know if you can read this
from here you can basically attach
information like is this data as it
approve for use you know what is the
does it have PII
what is the type of PII and there are
currently you know five data ties that
we support the supports string we
support double boolean enumerated and
date/time and using these five types you
can create really rich templates and you
can use these templates to create
individual tags that you can attach to
individual data assets the next slides
is sort of an illustration for example
let's assume that you have this you know
toy example of a customer table and you
have certain columns in that table
wouldn't it be great if you could have
some sort of a sticky note an electronic
sticky notify me some sort of a schema
ties tag that has somehow captured all
this rich information for example the
common thing that analysts do when they
come to work in the morning say ok I
need to generate a report I need to know
if the last night's ETL job ran
successfully I wish somebody could tell
me and I didn't have to call data
engineering yesterday what was the
status of the last night ETL job how
many rows were ingested did we have any
errors did we have any warnings now
imagine there was similar tagged the
data governance that that told you that
what is the data classification is it
public is it private is it sensitive
where in the life cycle is this data is
it in prod is it in tests is it
deprecated to be deleted where is it
stand what is the data quality time
right what's the completeness of this
data
what's the freshness of this data right
does it actually meet the criteria or
has it fallen off and somehow I should
you know look at it with suspicion
saying maybe this is not the right data
we allow you to create such schema ties
tags to capture all this rich business
metadata so that when you come across a
data asset it gives you the necessary
context to use it in a meaningful way we
also enable you to create tags at a
column level so you can say for these
columns the PII is true and this is the
type of PIR this column might have some
funny name but it's actually SSN we are
using social security number this has
email address there is another thing for
example
often times you come across a data a
column and say okay how am I supposed to
use this how was it calculated for
example in this case we say lifetime
value lifetime value of your customers
like okay what was the formula used to
calculate it how shall I interpret that
all that rich business metadata that you
need in order to really leverage your
data asset now can we actually put right
next to the data and it becomes
searchable so you can search by saying
show me show me everything that has PII
access now when I talk about discovery
one of the things that is really really
important is that who has access to what
right in many traditional data catalogs
you have to actually register your data
asset and then you had to set a separate
set of permission separate set of Ackles
what we have done is we say okay you
don't need to do that first of all we do
Auto ingestion of metadata and then we
honor the same ackles that govern data
assets in your source system so in this
example we have two users user one has
say deed access to all data sets in BQ
and user two has read access to only the
first three data sets has metadata read
access to the fourth data set and no
access to the fifth dataset the view
that user two has in data catalog is
that they can discover a B C and D then
they click on the D data asset though
they won't be able to see the actual
data when it comes to the last date acid
e since they do not have any access data
catalog search actually does a collects
and when you run the search in that 500
milliseconds that we try to return
results we probably run in 100,000 plus
a context to say this user should see
what what are they allowed to see and we
show them the right data assets so you
do not need to do any additional Ackles
and your there is no data exfiltration
of data or meta data exfiltration of any
kind so your data is safe in that sense
the Akal checks that i talked about also
apply to the business metadata tags so
in this case in this example we have
three sets of tags we have an ETL tag a
data governance tag and the data quality
time now data governance is able to
create tags that only they can see
because oftentimes they put very
sensitive
information in that metadata and maybe
they do not want everybody to be able to
see that so our metadata tags the
business tags are also accurate now many
of our customers come to us and say oh
this is great and they told us that at
the same time you know even though it's
programmatic and it has all these smarts
our customer still is is lots of data
where the column names are not correct
koala might say column 17 or something
but actually it has PII data what should
we do so we have worked with DLP to
provide the integration that I referred
to earlier and using that you can use
DLP to scan your data either you can do
full scan or you can do sample scan and
the integration enables you to leave the
data as is but attach the DLP will
automatically scan and attach the the
metadata that will identify your data to
say ok this is you know PII data and the
type of PII is let's say email address
and this is my confidence level like 99%
certain that this is the kind of data
which allows you to process large
amounts of data automatically and
identify PII information which can lead
to better data governance because then
you can say okay who should have access
to it why is this accessible to
everybody and then do the necessary
controls a brief this thing about
pricing we wanted to make data catalog
very accessible eminently accessible to
all our users and at the same time you
know we didn't want to make it entirely
free for various reasons that it will be
abused etc so how pricing is you know as
I mentioned here it's $100 per gigabyte
per month of stored metadata that is
business metadata there is no charge for
technical metadata because technical
metadata resides in the source systems
and the way we look at it you know you
have already paid for it you don't want
to charge again
also we give you 1 megabyte of business
metadata free so that you can try things
out in terms of API pricing there is a
second dimension and you know we have 1
million catalog API calls free included
for every user and we believe most users
would not need more than that
but in the off chance that you're
developing some application that calls
lots of API you know it's like $10 per
100,000 API per month so it's a very
attractive pricing we are working
closely with a number of partners
calibra informatica tableau and looker
and they will be using our API so I
mentioned the API eyes are open and free
you know we believe that it's your
metadata you can do whatever you want to
do with it and using those api's they
will be providing integration in future
so that your on-prem metadata can also
be ingested into data catalog so that
you will have one catalog to find all
your data assets and you won't have to
go to multiple places so at this point
I'd like to switch over to a brief demo
so I wanted to show you what the data
catalog looks like it's early we are
close to beta we are not there yet in
the next few weeks you know hopefully we
will update some of these things but I
want to show you how data catalog looks
like this will show up in your console
and any of you if you want to start
accessing data catalog today I can
whitelist you and you can start using
the Alpha that's available so the data
catalog UI looks as follows it's
organized along the lines of cards we
have different cards there is a card for
exploring data assets and each of these
links are clickable and you can just
click them to look for data assets and
you can go back here you can create your
tag templates you can explore your
tacked in place you can create your tag
templates there is search tips you can
search using tags asset types column
bucket names as I mentioned it's a rich
facet search and there's a link to an
online documentation on the left side we
show the popular tables in this current
incarnation it says okay we look at the
usage say in bigquery and which are the
really popular tables we want to show
you so that you don't even have to
search for this if we plan to develop it
in this manner that in future it will be
more customized my goal is that 50% of
the time you shouldn't even have to go
for you know the search box you should
say oh how did it this read my mind this
is exactly what I was looking for the
other 50% of the time maybe you go
search for the data
such that you want briefly I want to
show you for example if I look for all
tables and views and I so did that too
quickly I guess so we have all these
search results here that match the table
I haven't even looked for anything in
particular in terms of keyword but I
found this table and this is in data
catalog it shows me the schema it shows
me the details and there is an
integration built-in with bigquery so
from data catalog if you like that
particular table you click on it it
launches bigquery and you can start
querying you can look at the preview and
you can you know this is the integration
we provide but in addition in addition
if I say bookings let's say I found a
table and in this table have all these
tags the kind of tags that I talked
about we have the data discovery tag
data governance tag quality tag template
tag so let's look at the data governance
tag this sort of illustrates how I can
actually categorize the data and I say
you know I have the data classification
as an enumerated type and I can choose
the category to say is it public
sensitive confidential regulatory I can
specify the data lifecycle is it in prep
is it in test is it in prod etcetera and
I can specify all kinds of rich metadata
tags as I talked about right the other
thing that I wanted to demonstrate is
how we do Akal controls so in this case
I have two windows and here I'm logged
in as an admin who has access to
everything and here I'm logged in as an
analyst who has access to only you know
limited things and in this case when I
look for bookings
I should find the same set of tables I
should find the same set of tables right
on the other hand if I go to save
Finance I find these two tables here and
these two tables here now in this case
when I click on this table and try to
access the data I should be able to
access the data because I do have
permission I can see this data I can
review this
in the other case I'm an analyst I can
discover this data I can discover the
metadata but if I actually try to access
the data I should get an error I see
this error message and I cannot review
it now
that shows that the Ackles are working
if similarly I go to the data I said
that I do not have access to as you know
as a as an admin have access to HR data
I see all this as an analyst I go to HR
data I don't have access to HR data that
just quickly shows the two things that I
wanted to highlight one is the schema
ties metadata the tags that we create
and the second thing is the Ackles at
this point I would like to invite my
bodies from project
Renata and Dimas who have as I mentioned
just to give the context who have
developed the go check front-end because
they had they had a front-end that they
were using and now they have kept the
same front-end but they using the data
catalog back in without further thank
you ii thank you google for having us
here and thank you guys for joining our
session here we are from go-jek my name
is Nima's I am data warehouse manager in
go-jek before we are going into how we
are implementing the catalog API in our
data discovery tools we would like to
introduce go-jek to you first
so Gajic is actually a technology
company that have purpose to improve
people's quality of life
okay and so I believe not many of you
know that actually gojek starting as a
call center in 2010 for the object
services which is object actually is a
term in indonesia for motorcycle
rappelling or motorcycle taxi five years
and after that we are launched our
mobile apps with three initial surfaces
which is go right go San and go shop and
starting in 2016 we would like to become
a mobile app for daily needs and we are
starting to expand into more than 200
profiles in Indonesia and
more than 20 surfaces and just last year
in 2018 we are making history by doing
international expansion to Vietnam
Thailand and Singapore in the beginning
Gajic is will to provide a solution for
our informal sectors because here
Indonesia we have so many challenge for
the informal sector some of the
challenge that would like logics office
first will it take we would like to
solve inefficiency of time and
accessibility but for the customer and
service provider because in early days
if you would like to have an object
services we need to go to the main
street we need to find an available
available object there and in the other
hand most of the time from the surface
or fader itself are wasting to waiting
for the customer rather than providing
the surface and the last one go Jake
would like also to empower our service
provider for the financial services so
they are able to plan their future
instead of only earning money for one
day so hi everyone my name is Renata and
I'm currently the product manager and
business intelligence core team at Kojak
so like just what they must say we at go
Jack
we are here to solve real problems and
[Music]
when we started off in 2010 we started
off with just one service which is just
a ride hailing business however as time
as you can imagine in Indonesia we are a
developing as well as growing nation so
there are a lot of problems that are
there to be solved a lot of opportunity
that we can help on and that's the
reason why we grow to now more than 20
services in 2018 so when you when you
hear like more than 20 services like
what can you provide to your user there
seems to be like too many services so we
provide user ranging from payment
services to financial services to as
well as lifestyle services
like go glam so Gollum is basically you
can get connected to professional
hairstylist and that hairstylist can
come to your home and get you a fresh
new look or we have go daily which is
basically a daily subscription service
so you can get deliver your daily
household needs like tea juice rice a
Maryland a scheduled basis either you
wanted a weekly basis or a monthly basis
so we're not only growing in terms of
the number services that we are
providing to our user but also
regionally so we are now live not only
obviously in Indonesia but also in
Singapore Thailand and Vietnam and user
have been trusting out by you can see
the numbers with a hundred and thirty
million apps download we are partnering
with more than two million drivers and
four hundred thousand more merchants and
we are now just acting more than one
hundred million monthly transactions so
as our business grows so does our data
as you can imagine when you add one
service time and or you add you expand
to one more region it doesn't goes
linearly it just doesn't go like when
you had one services you had one
database it doesn't go like that so the
data economy become much more complex
even though we have we are using
bigquery as our data warehouse which
already simplify a lot of this
complexities however data is not just
raw data that you got from your
application right it also includes
dashboard that you have in a lot of data
visualization tool like meta base
tableau and also announces that a lot of
your data teams has created like we have
the base intelligent team we have data
science we have free search team and on
top of that as well you have your people
inside your company which also provide a
lot of those data so on top of this
complexity and the variety of data that
you have and that we have
we are soul experiencing growing number
of volume of data so in a month-to-month
basis we are growing 32% in a man-to-man
in their cell volume data that we are
getting from our application and also we
have more than 700 resources right now
that we need to aggregate as a leader
team and more in tens of thousands of
dashboard and all of this combined with
the complexity combined with very
demanding but we love them user more
than 2,000 user in a weekly app in a
weekly basis so Oh everything combined
leads to some major pain points that we
face in a daily basis and it's not just
a state a team but also our user right
so the first of all mainly it's you it
creates two main pain points which is
productivity and government but in a
real sense it's actually the times that
you actually need to spend when you want
to search for a particular question
right you can imagine like outside a
company when you have a question you can
simply Google search it and get the
reference we'd all live through and
provide an answer and you'll want to do
the same when you're in a company right
like us so it just takes so much time a
person for who to answer a particular
question they would eat more than one
hour on average sometimes it would be
more than one day because we just
realized that
oops we don't have that data so we might
need to go to the product team and
actually produce their dose data and
secondly it's also taking a lot of time
for us part of team like pm's engineer a
lot of them actually end up going to us
because they want to ask like hey I know
that it is there but I'm not quite sure
whether the video quality is on check so
can you run some query and check it for
us or so I know that it is there I check
it by myself the data quality is pretty
good but I'm not sure whether
already a beta in for 2d so a lot of
this thing also adds up to our plate as
well and it takes a lot of our time
which we are not supposed to be doing
that we're supposed to be building
products so and the last part is because
people finally at heart and takes too
much time to actually find data they
could recreate a lot of the data object
that we already provide to them and
recreating a lot of dashboard as well so
that's the reason why we create our own
internal tool which is a data discovery
tool which we called EDX which basically
it's literally like a we want to build
it like a Google search for all of the
data that we have at gojek so it
compiles a lot of the main data products
that um people people are using inside
our company which is bigquery dashboard
dashboard from meta base and as well a
lot of analysis they are made from the
data teams and what's powerful with this
is actually I'll reduce a lot of the
time that was previously wasted to get
to to get to the answer quickly so now
I'm gonna pass it down to demas so they
must here we'll talk about the backend
of data X yes well as the limitation and
why we choose data catalog okay thank
you I believe all of you there will be
here how great that X is and however
this is the back end of it so we are
using bigquery as our main of that data
sources which have all of the meta that
are there and then what happen is we
have one job which is extracting all of
our meta data and we grouping it into
its types like which one is the data set
which one is to the tables which one is
the column level after that we store all
of the metadata under the clause sequel
and export it back to transform
mitigation and push it back to the
Alaska search which is Alexis's will
become our back-end for the data deck so
it doesn't need to go to the cross
sequel but it needs to go to the galaxy
charts by having this architecture
actually we are solving that solution
but we create another one so what
happened is now
our maintenance is more and more complex
because once we are giving my queries or
metadata a lot of requests coming in
like can you please provide metadata for
google storage can you please provide
metadata for tableau dashboard all of
them are coming into our it goes request
and the second one is our search to
slide our search result might be
inaccurate why because all of these jobs
are running in daily and the third one
is engineering effort to maintain of the
metadata since the number of our
bigquery tables columns is increasing
instantly can be we have more than
36,000 of table and more than 700 column
in Arabic query so when we are facing
this difficulty that a catalog team came
to us and they have data catalog as a
solution we are starting our
collaboration collaborations since July
2nd 2018 as an early access user for
this program it's a great to have
checker and a team they are really
supporting us for our needs in solving
data discovery issue is like an example
they provide one of the not gs client
API even before it is released in the
Alpha and decide that we are also
serving number of development because we
know there are so many feature that will
be a fillable data catalog and we do not
need to be flopping that so from that
prefer certificate as a sector we are
going to discipline sleep simplicity
architecture it's all here that addicts
connect to the data catalog API what is
the advantages by having this
architecture first there is really no
oppression required to maintain all of
the infrastructure and a fill ability of
the metadata why because the tackle at
the catalog are able to provide a
real-time metadata once we are creating
I'm equitable then it will be
automatically shown in the taffeta API
and the third one we believe with the
catalog there will be more and more
feature coming in and it will be met as
more focus into creating a business and
technical metadata asset of the flopping
the data discovery tools okay I think we
can go to the demo for ease
it's good to the demo2 cool okay let's
start so for the first case okay so
before we start this is dummy data even
though the schema is exactly what we
have internally but all this value our
dummy data so let's start so one first
use case is for example I'm an analyst
and I want to find I want to find a
commission for a particular merchant for
their goof with booking so let's search
for that okay so you would like to have
an Alice's for net let's find out the
merchant Commission go for okay okay
here it is a result hmm okay let's see
hmm okay from all of this option I want
to see a summary table that is updated
daily so that means our aviation would
be s for summary and D for D let's
choose the first one cool so as a first
result is this it they're both details
okay cool
I want to see where it lies on it's in
project B I go Jack it's indeed a set
axes and type table cool let's go to the
schema and see I'm particularly
interested on metrics name called
merchant Commission it should be there
here it is hmm okay so that's solve it
but let I want to check whether the
beacon data quality is on track whether
it's actually trustful can we go to the
tax and see sure here it is we have two
kind of tax the technical furnace
metadata mm-hmm okay so did a quality
score 100% so it's perfect let's just go
to the source to go to the link and use
that data sure collate this
so that's the first use case as an
analyst
you just want to find out a specific
keyword and it will redirect you
directly to the data source it will go
to the table in bigquery
so on the next use case which is as data
governments personnel so for example
like the easiest way like the most basic
way to figure out you have an inequality
issue as to is from the raw differences
between one day to another right so
let's take the extreme so let's search
for the row differences there is more
than 1 million sure that the type this
first row difference is the difference
this is 1 million ok no more yeah just
for not we are still using AG because we
are in earlier Pfizer but I believe it
will change the feature
go for it yes let's check
hopefully ok so apparently we have find
an issue in this particular table after
you go points for transaction so let's
click on it and see oops
here it is ok so there's more than four
million growth differences hmm let's I
would like to know what's the source for
this table so maybe let's search for
like future transaction yeah sure
because it is line is staging data set
which is cities in the route data layer
so we can go directly to the Google
asuras because it is source of the table
let's find out for the future
transaction and go through the Google
Sites first let me see the file ah yeah
are you this we find the source of this
table cool so as you can see here you'll
be able to locate the where the bucket
lies and also the file path as well and
let's see the file as well within the
forth
ok sure so by using the Takato lock API
actually it's automatically transform
our to because already into a pattern so
we know which one of the files
from them that we need to change at our
request so by using this you can
directly just copy and paste it and go
directly to the GCL file and create a
table and bakery and being able to
analyze it and which part does go wrong
and fix it yep that's cool so so from
all of our such forum our session
basically what we're trying to say is
data discovery as a painful for us we
have built it by ourselves and faced a
lot of problems by maintaining by
ourself and it just makes much more
sense for us to actually use data
catalog and the flexibility that it
actually gave us by using the API and
having our own front-end interface which
can cover a lot of our like custom needs
it really does work and help
[Music]